Générique
...
- Alexandre Poussart: Bonjour.
Très heureux
de vous retrouver
dans ce nouveau numéro.
Nous allons revivre
les temps forts
de la semaine au Parlement.
- Kathia Gilder:
Nous accueillons
cette semaine Sylvain Maillard.
Bonjour.
Député de Paris et président
du groupe Renaissance
à l'Assemblée nationale.
Beaucoup d'actu pour vous.
- Alexandre Poussart:
Le moment fort
de cette semaine,
c'est la déclaration
de politique générale
de Gabriel Attal.
C'était mardi devant les députés.
Il a annoncé
toute une série de mesures
pour rétablir
l'ordre, l'autorité
dans le pays et conserver
notre souveraineté.
Un discours
qui n'a pas convaincu
les parlementaires de gauche.
Ils dénoncent
la politique trop marquée
à droite du gouvernement.
Gabriel Attal
n'a pas non plus convaincu
Les Républicains,
dont il a besoin
pour faire passer
ces textes au Parlement.
Le texte important
à faire adopter,
c'est l'inscription
de l'IVG
dans la Constitution.
Première étape
franchie cette semaine
avec le vote favorable
des députés.
La balle est dans le camp
du Sénat.
L'issue est incertaine.
- Kathia Gilder:
Le plus jeune Premier ministre
de la Ve République a donc
fait sa déclaration
de politique générale
à l'Assemblée nationale.
Ce moment incontournable
est l'occasion
pour un Premier
ministre d'exposer
les objectifs
du gouvernement
et de fixer le cap.
Voyons les quelques lignes
fixées
lors de cette déclaration.
- Pendant 1h20,
le Premier ministre
a dévoilé sa feuille de route.
- Gabriel Attal:
Parler aux Français,
c'est entendre
les appels à l'action,
pour le travail,
pour qu'il paye mieux
et toujours plus,
que les activités soient partout
et pour tous,
pour nos services publics,
pour qu'ils soient
accessibles
et de qualité partout
et pour tous,
pour l'autorité
et le civisme, le respect
des droits
et devoirs partout
et pour tous,
pour un environnement
plus respirable
partout et pour tous.
- Gabriel Attal veut
répondre aux inquiétudes
de la France qui doute,
et notamment
la France des classes moyennes.
- Gabriel Attal:
Je veux m'adresser
à tous ces Français souvent
de la classe moyenne,
toujours au rendez-vous
de leurs responsabilités
qui ne se plaignent pas
alors qu'ils ont souvent
le sentiment de subir.
A ces Français,
ceux qui ont le sentiment
d'avoir tous les devoirs
et peu de droits,
à ces Français
qui ne demandent
pas la lune mais simplement
de pouvoir vivre
de leur travail.
- Le plus jeune
Premier ministre
de la Ve République
mise également
sur l'autorité
avec des formules
aux accents sarkozystes.
- Gabriel Attal:
Tu casses, tu répares,
tu salis, tu nettoies,
tu défies l'autorité,
on t'apprend à la respecter.
- Il déroule le programme
des prochains mois,
loi sur la fonction
publique, texte
sur la justice
des mineurs,
mais le gouvernement veut
aussi faire passer
des réformes par voie
réglementaire.
Ce sera le cas pour l'AME,
l'aide médicale d'Etat.
- Kathia Gilder:
Voilà pour les lignes
de force de ce discours.
Gabriel Attal a fait
beaucoup d'annonces,
mais il veut désmicardiser,
débureaucratiser
la France.
Est-ce que ce
volontarisme
à tous
les étages
ne vous rappelle pas quelqu'un?
C'était quand même
un discours assez
à droite.
Nicolas Sarkozy
n'aurait pas dit mieux.
- Sylvain Maillard:
J'entends la réponse
à ce que nous
avons entendu
dans toute nos circonscriptions,
faire
en sorte de protéger,
la valeur travail,
c'est aussi
ce que nous avons toujours porté.
C'était une déclaration
de politique générale assez forte.
C'était un discours
assez puissant.
Il faut
que les politiques
que nous portons
s'incarnent
dans notre quotidien.
Vous votez
des lois,
ça ne s'incarne pas assez
dans le quotidien.
- Kathia Gilder:
C'est un peu débloquer
le système.
- Sylvain Maillard:
Nous vivons
une grande crise agricole
depuis plusieurs jours.
Ca montre bien le fait
que la bureaucratie
nous empêche de faire
notre travail.
On le sent partout.
Sur le logement, pareil.
Je vois souvent
des maires qui me disent
qu'ils ne
construisent pas
pour des raisons
différentes,
mais il y a toujours
des recours
en permanence,
c'est compliqué,
ils disent
que ça va leur prendre
un temps fou.
L'administration doit
être là pour aider,
elle ne doit pas être là
pour empêcher.
C'est ce que le Premier
ministre a voulu porter.
- Alexandre Poussart:
Gabriel Attal veut désmicardiser
la France,
mais au fond,
est-ce que tous
les bas salaires
qui augmentent
peu,
est-ce que ce n'est pas
le résultat
de la politique
d'Emmanuel Macron
depuis 7 ans?
-
Sylvain Maillard:
Ce n'est pas tout à fait ça.
Quand on dit
"désmicardiser",
quand vous regardez
une grille de salaire,
ça coûte très cher
pour augmenter quelqu'un
qui est au SMIC.
Pour son patron,
ça va coûter presque 400 euros.
Il y a beaucoup d'aides
et de défiscalisations
au niveau du SMIC.
La grille de salaire se comprime.
Au fond, y compris
pour le fait
de ne pas payer
d'impôt sur le revenu,
pour les avantages
sociaux,
comme pour les crèches
et les cantines scolaires,
vous n'avez plus intérêt
à aller demander
une augmentation
quand vous êtes au SMIC.
Il y a beaucoup
moins de revendications
pour ceux qui sont au SMIC
d'aller gagner 20
ou 30 euros
de plus,
parce que ça leur fait
perdre de l'argent.
- Alexandre Poussart:
Comment vous augmentez
les salaires
qui sont juste au-dessus
du SMIC?
-
Sylvain Maillard:
C'est ce que nous avons proposé.
Une majorité
des députés Renaissance
sont aux côtés du gouvernement.
Nous allons trouver
le moyen de remettre
de la progressivité
dans les salaires.
Quand vous commencez
à travailler,
vous pourriez
commencer au SMIC,
il faut qu'il y ait
une évolution
de carrière.
- Alexandre Poussart:
Ce n'est pas l'Etat
qui a la main sur les salaires.
- Sylvain Maillard:
Le SMIC,
c'est un référentiel.
On commence au SMIC
et il y a une progression.
Vous apprenez
des compétences
dans votre métier,
vous êtes de mieux
en mieux.
Comment faire en sorte
que quelqu'un reste motivé
dans une entreprise
s'il s'aperçoit que,
quels que soient ses efforts,
il reste scotché
au même salaire?
Ce n'est pas possible.
Il faut qu'on arrive
à casser ce système
qui est très administratif.
Il bloque certains salaires.
- Alexandre Poussart:
La solution n'est
donc pas encore très claire.
- Sylvain Maillard:
On y travaille.
Il y a les aides d'Etat
qui permettent d'accompagner
les primes,
vous avez raison,
et il y a aussi les aides
qui s'enclenchent
parce que vous
êtes au SMIC
et qui ne sont plus là
quand vous n'est
plus au SMIC.
Il faut qu'on arrive
à mettre
tout sur la table
et que l'on fasse
en sorte de trouver
la solution
pour retrouver
une progressivité
dans les salaires.
- Kathia Gilder:
Gabriel Attal veut aussi
poursuivre la réforme
de l'assurance-chômage.
Il a annoncé
que les chômeurs en fin
de droits,
qui pouvaient percevoir
une allocation spécifique
qui leur donne droit
à valider des trimestres
de retraite, seront désormais
au RSA.
Est-ce que c'est
une manière
de les responsabiliser
ou même
de les culpabiliser?
- Sylvain Maillard:
Il y a deux philosophie.
Une personne
qui est au chômage,
on doit tout mettre en oeuvre
avec France Travail,
avec les formations
au quotidien,
on doit être là
pour les aider à retrouver
du travail.
Nous,
ce que nous ne voulons pas,
c'est indemniser et voir
ce qui se passe.
Quand on regarde
ce qui se passe,
on voit
que ceux qui sont vraiment
en difficulté, on doit
plus les accompagner
parce qu'ils ne
retrouveront
pas du travail par eux-mêmes.
Il faut
qu'on les forme
et qu'on les accompagne.
Ceux qui retrouvent
facilement du travail,
quand on regarde
la courbe,
quelques semaines
avant la fin
de leurs droits,
il y a une accélération
de la recherche de travail.
Ce n'est pas une question
de profiter.
Il y a un système
qui est l'assurance-chômage
et qui est devenu
une autre forme
de revenus pour certains
concitoyens.
On travaille
une partie du temps
et ensuite, on s'arrête
et on se remet
à travailler ensuite.
On veut faire
en sorte
que ce soit plus difficile
de le faire.
Le système ne tiendra pas.
On veut baisser
les impôts, on veut
avoir plus de salaire
net, mais s'il
y a une partie
de la population
qui ne travaille pas,
il faut le financer.
Ca coûte de l'argent.
Il faut mieux accompagner
les demandeurs d'emploi
tout de suite et continuer
tout le long.
Ceux qui ne jouent pas le jeu,
il faut faire
quelque chose.
- Alexandre Poussart:
Une question
sur la crise agricole.
Gabriel Attal a fait
de nouvelles annonces
pour les agriculteurs
toute cette semaine.
Les blocages ont été
majoritairement levés.
Dans ces annonces,
il y a la mise
en pause du plan
Ecophyto du gouvernement
pour réduire l'usage
des pesticides.
Est-ce que ça veut
dire que l'écologie
et la qualité
alimentaire
sont en train de payer
le prix
de cette crise agricole?
- Sylvain Maillard:
Je crois qu'il faut prendre
un peu de recul.
Cette crise agricole
nous montre
une chose.
On ne peut pas laisser
nos agriculteurs.
En même temps, on leur dit
qu'il faut assurer
la souveraineté
alimentaire,
mais ils sont face
à des produits
qui n'ont pas les mêmes
normes
que les autres.
J'ai confiance en la France.
Elle est capable
d'être compétitive.
Ce que nous faisons,
c'est que très souvent,
nous avons probablement
la surtransposition
la plus forte d'Europe.
Nous, on s'aligne
au niveau européen.
Il faut que ce qui est décidé
au niveau européen s'applique
à tous les pays d'Europe.
- Kathia Gilder:
Là, vous visez le traité Mercosur.
- Sylvain Maillard: Pas que.
- Kathia Gilder:
Emmanuel Macron vient
de bloquer la ratification
de ce traité
qui est en cours
depuis très longtemps.
Ca veut dire que vous,
macroniste,
qui étiez porteur d'une Europe
libérale,
êtes devenu souverainiste?
- Sylvain Maillard:
Je suis un libéral,
je souhaite plus d'échanges.
Plus il y a d'échanges,
plus il y a de création
de richesses dans le monde...
- Kathia Gilder:
Mais pas avec le Mercosur.
- Sylvain Maillard:
Il y a des choses
qui sont intéressantes
dans le Mercosur,
mais sur la question
agricole,
ça ne va pas.
Les produits
qui pourraient arriver
en France
ne correspondent pas aux normes
que nous acceptons en France.
Nous dirons "non"
tant que les normes
ne seront pas les normes
européennes
de produits agricoles.
- Alexandre Poussart:
Gabriel Attal
a également détaillé
toutes ces mesures
aux sénateurs mercredi,
dans une déclaration.
Il n'a pas reçu un accueil
très chaleureux
à droite comme à gauche.
- Sous la coupole
du palais du Luxembourg
et face à une autre
majorité, Gabriel Attal
a prononcé
une nouvelle version
de son discours
de politique générale.
Pendant 1h30,
il a déroulé son programme
de gouvernement face
à des sénateurs
pour certains dubitatifs.
- L'illusion macroniste
du social libéralisme
de 2017 aura duré un printemps.
Vous n'avez fait
que semer les graines
de la colère
qui sont en train de germer
sur le terreau
de vos choix de société
et votre vocabulaire
guerrier n'est
que le signe avant tout d'une
grande faiblesse.
- Idéologiquement opposé
à Patrick Kanner,
Bruno Retailleau
démontre aussi
une certaine hostilité.
- N'attendez pas
de nous que nous devenions
macronistes.
Vous dites
que vous avez confiance.
Nous, nous n'avons pas confiance.
Nous avons appris à nous méfier.
Il faudra
que cette confiance,
vous puissiez la reconstruire.
Le sentiment qui domine,
c'est précisément
la défiance.
- A l'inverse,
Hervé Marseille,
chef de l'Union
centriste, appelle
à la responsabilité de chacun.
- Hervé Marseille:
Cette responsabilité pèse
sur vos épaules,
elle pèse aussi
sur nos épaules.
Si vous échouez,
si nous échouons,
vous et nous,
nous savons qui arbitrera
nos différends
en 2027 et alors,
il sera trop tard pour pleurer.
- Un Sénat
qui ne fera pas plus de cadeaux
à Gabriel Attal qu'à
Elisabeth Borne
et sans qui la réforme
des retraites
et la loi immigration
n'auraient pu
être adoptées.
- Alexandre Poussart:
On l'a entendu,
les sénateurs
Les Républicains n'ont
plus confiance
dans le gouvernement.
Ils ont le sentiment
d'avoir été trahis
par Emmanuel Macron
sur la loi immigration.
Est-ce que vous craignez la fin
de l'entente cordiale
avec les LR?
- Sylvain Maillard:
Je ne sais pas s'il
y a une entente cordiale.
On continuera
à travailler
avec les sénateurs.
Sur l'immigration,
je l'ai vu de l'intérieur.
Tout a été mis sur la table.
Nous leur avons dit
qu'une partie
des articles
qu'ils proposaient
n'étaient pas constitutionnels.
Ils le savaient parfaitement.
Le Conseil
constitutionnel a fait
son travail.
Il a fait en sorte
de dire que 31 articles
n'étaient pas constitutionnels.
Je ne comprends pas bien
ce jeu
que pourraient jouer les LR.
C'était leur stratégie.
Ils voulaient démontrer
que la Constitution devait
être changée.
Ils nous l'ont toujours dit.
Je ne comprends pas très bien
ce changement,
si ce n'est peut-être une posture.
- Kathia Gilder:
Les sénateurs centristes veulent
réintroduire
dans une proposition
de loi certaines des mesures
de la loi immigration
qui avaient bien
été votées
par vous au Parlement,
mais qui ont été retoquées
par le Conseil
constitutionnel,
notamment le durcissement
du regroupement familial
ou encore l'accès
à certaines prestations.
Est-ce que vous,
si ça revient,
vous serez cohérent
et vous voterez
ces mesures retoquées?
- Sylvain Maillard:
La loi immigration
est derrière nous.
Nous avons voté
des mesures très fortes.
Le coeur
de ce que nous voulions
a été voté.
Sur les 27 articles,
26 ont été votés.
Ce que nous demandent
les Français,
ce n'est pas de faire
des lois
après des lois.
Ils veulent des actions.
Le travail est au niveau
du gouvernement,
de nos administrations,
de nos policiers,
de nos gendarmes.
Il faut du résultat.
Il faut faire en sorte
que ça fonctionne.
C'est ce que demandent
les Français.
On a un très beau
texte qui vient
d'être promulgué.
Maintenant,
il faut l'appliquer
tout de suite.
-
Alexandre Poussart:
Ce n'est pas très cohérent.
Vous aviez voté
en décembre un texte
de compromis
avec les centristes
et avec Les Républicains.
Certaines mesures
ont été retoquées
pour des raisons formelles.
Pourquoi
ne pas les réintroduire?
- Sylvain Maillard:
Le coeur
de ce que nous voulions,
les articles
les plus importants
pour nous,
tout a été validé et promulgué.
Nous voulions
faire en sorte
que ceux qui travaillent
dans les métiers
en tension puissent
être régularisés.
Tout a été validé
par le Conseil constitutionnel
et promulgué.
Maintenant, on a un texte,
on doit faire
en sorte que ça s'incarne.
Il faut que ça s'applique.
Les Français,
c'est ce qu'ils nous demandent.
Faire en sorte
que les 4000 personnes
qui n'étaient pas
expulsables
alors que ce sont des criminels
étrangers,
il faut qu'ils soient expulsés.
Il y a du travail à faire.
C'est ce que nous demandent
les Français.
- Kathia Gilder:
Vous dites que l'urgence,
c'est d'appliquer cette loi
qui a été votée.
Pas de nouveau
débat au Parlement
sur l'immigration,
mais du coup, l'annonce faite
par Gabriel Attal de décider
de réformer l'AME,
comme Elisabeth Borne
s'y était engagée
lors d'un compromis
avec la droite,
ça passera par voie réglementaire.
Ca vous arrange, finalement?
- Sylvain Maillard:
Il n'y
aura pas de débat au Parlement.
Je vous invite à relire la lettre
d'Elisabeth Borne.
C'est un engagement qui sera tenu.
Il engage la majorité.
L'objectif,
c'est de faire des lois
ou de faire
une politique qui existe
sur le terrain?
L'AME, on peut en discuter.
J'ai plein de propositions.
Il y a un rapport à la base
de la réflexion.
Il y a des choses
que l'on peut améliorer
sur l'accès au soin,
mais nous,
on a d'autres propositions.
Je pense à titre
personnel que l'AME doit
être plus rapide.
Quelqu'un qui arrive
sur notre territoire doit pouvoir
bénéficier de l'AME.
Quand il arrive,
c'est à ce moment-là
qu'il doit être soigné
plus vite,
mais peut-être
avec une durée
moins longue
de l'obtention de l'AME.
Après, vous pouvez rentrer
dans un parcours classique
d'assurance.
Quand on travaille,
ça veut dire
qu'on s'intègre.
Tous les vaccins
qui sont obligatoires
pour chacun d'entre
nous, il faut faire
en sorte que tous
ceux qui arrivent
sur notre territoire
soient vaccinés.
Ce serait
une mesure efficace
pour la personne
qui arrive
sur notre territoire.
Ce serait une belle évolution.
Tout ça, c'est réglementaire.
- Alexandre Poussart:
On va évoquer
un sujet qui vous concerne
précisément.
Le Premier ministre s'est
déclaré favorable
à la réforme du scrutin
des élections municipales
à Paris, Lyon et Marseille.
C'est vous qui avez déposé
un texte
sur ce sujet.
Est-ce que ce texte
est prêt et ce sera
sur quel calendrier?
- Sylvain Maillard:
J'ai travaillé
sur ce sujet avec mon collègue
David Amiel.
Nous travaillons dessus
depuis plusieurs mois.
Construire une proposition
de loi prend
du temps.
On a encore plusieurs
propositions
à faire.
Un Parisien égale une voix,
un Lyonnais égale
une voix, un Marseillais
égale une voix.
Ca devrait être comme ça partout.
Dans chaque ville,
il y a un maire
ou une maire
qui a été élu
sans être majoritaire.
On ne veut plus de ça.
On veut faire en sorte
que chaque maire
soit le maire
ou la maire
de tout le monde.
Pour Paris, par exemple,
on a une maire
de Paris qui est maire
de l'est parisien.
Elle s'occupe
plus de l'est parisien
parce que ce sont ses mairies
d'arrondissement.
Elle ne s'en occupe pas
très bien,
mais elle s'occupe
plus de ça
que du reste.
J'y suis très attaché.
Ca fait partie
de l'ADN des villes.
On propose un principe
très simple
avec deux urnes.
Il y aura une élection
pour les maires d'arrondissements,
comme dans n'importe
quelle autre ville,
et l'autre
pour le maire de Paris,
de Lyon et de Marseille.
Une liste du Conseil
municipal
et une liste par arrondissement.
- Kathia Gilder:
Quel est le but
de cette réforme?
C'est pour reprendre
Paris à la gauche?
Est-ce que vous serez
capables de faire
une union des forces?
- Sylvain Maillard:
L'objectif,
ce n'est pas un mode
de scrutin
qui vous fait gagner une élection.
On veut redonner envie
aux gens d'aller voter.
Tout est joué d'avance.
En fonction des secteurs
ou des arrondissements,
on sait déjà qui va gagner.
On perd l'envie
de s'impliquer
dans sa ville.
Ces trois villes
perdent des habitants,
comme par hasard.
15.000 personnes
quittent Paris
par an.
- Kathia Gilder:
On a un calendrier
pour ça?
- Sylvain Maillard:
On déposera un texte
au début du printemps
pour un examen
en séance à l'Assemblée
nationale
que je souhaite
au milieu du printemps.
Ensuite, on verra
avec les sénateurs.
On voudrait que ce soit voté
en première
lecture avant les Jeux.
- Kathia Gilder:
On va terminer
avec le feu vert
à l'inscription
dans la Constitution
de la liberté
des femmes de recourir à l'IVG.
Peu après ce vote
solennel, la présidente
de l'Assemblée
nationale a écrit
un tweet.
Je vous propose
d'écouter la réaction
du ministre qui a porté le texte,
Eric Dupond-Moretti.
- Ce soir,
l'Assemblée nationale
et le gouvernement
n'ont pas manqué
leur rendez-vous
avec l'histoire
des femmes.
Je vais convaincre le Sénat
avec détermination,
humilité et,
naturellement,
avec tout le respect
que l'on doit
à toutes les consciences
que cette réforme
est une réforme utile.
Je veux convaincre
le Sénat
que c'est une réforme juste.
Je vais m'atteler
à convaincre le Sénat
que cette réforme,
nous la devons
à toutes les femmes
de notre pays, convaincre
le Sénat qu'il est grand temps,
en 2024, d'inscrire
dans la Constitution
la liberté d'avorter,
pour les femmes.
C'est une liberté
fondamentale
que les femmes
puissent disposer
comme elles l'entendent
de leur corps.
- Kathia Gilder:
Pour être définitivement adopté,
ce projet de loi
constitutionnelle
qui veut inscrire l'IVG
dans la Constitution doit
être voté à la virgule
près à l'identique
par l'Assemblée et le Sénat.
Gérard Larcher
et Bruno Retailleau
ont dit un peu
leur opposition claire
pour inscrire l'IVG
dans la Constitution.
Est-ce que vous craignez
que cette réforme
soit empêchée par le Sénat?
- Sylvain Maillard:
Je veux d'abord
vous dire la fierté
qui est la mienne
et des députés
de mon groupe
d'avoir voté ce texte.
C'était un moment très fort
à l'Assemblée nationale,
dans une journée
forte, juste
après la déclaration
de politique générale,
mais c'était un moment
extrêmement fort.
Nous pensons
que c'est important
de l'inscrire
dans la Constitution.
Nous voulons faire
en sorte que le Sénat
ne soit pas bloquant là-dessus.
Je crois qu'il doit
être facilitant.
Ca doit nous regrouper.
On doit faire en sorte
que ce soit constitutionnalisé.
Ce serait un signal
extraordinaire.
Ce serait la première fois
dans le monde qu'un pays
constitutionnalise l'IVG.
C'est un message dingue
à l'heure actuelle.
Pardon de le dire
comme ça,
on est dans un monde
où les droits
des femmes régressent partout.
Nous, on enverrait,
en France, le signal
de dire
que ce n'est pas inéluctable
et qu'on se bat pour ça.
- Alexandre Poussart:
Il y aura un débat
au Sénat très précis
sur cette révision
constitutionnelle.
Votre texte prévoit
la liberté garantie
de recourir à l'IVG
pour les femmes.
Les sénateurs estiment
que ça revient
à mettre
le "droit" à l'IVG
dans la Constitution.
Ils préfèrent mettre seulement
le mot "liberté".
- Sylvain Maillard:
C'est une discussion
que nous avons eue
avant le projet
de loi.
Je pense que c'est un bon
compromis.
"Liberté garantie",
ce serait une construction
parfaite entre l'Assemblée
et le Sénat.
On verra ce que propose
le Sénat,
mais j'ai confiance.
Le message
de l'Assemblée
était très fort.
- Kathia Gilder:
Même Marine Le Pen
a voté pour.
Les sénateurs
devront assumer
d'être à la droite
de Marine Le Pen.
- Sylvain Maillard:
C'est un débat
qui est en dehors de la politique.
C'est plus haut que ça.
Je souhaite
qu'ils entendent
que cette écriture
a embrassé l'intégralité
des groupes politiques
à l'Assemblée nationale.
Ce n'est pas si fréquent que ça.
Dans un moment aussi fort
d'unité nationale,
je pense que le Sénat
doit l'entendre.
Ca lui donnera
probablement la force
de voter une écriture conforme.
- Alexandre Poussart:
Ce sera le mot
de la fin.
Merci beaucoup
d'avoir été notre invité.
- Kathia Gilder: Merci à tous.
A la semaine prochaine.